And in my calculation A is 2. And, the reason
is the normalizer over here is a half, from
three to three and a half. To multiply a half
with 2 gives us the area of 1 which is what
we want to have for density. Now, what’s
interesting here? A is larger than 1. Probabilities
are never larger than 1. They are bound to the
above by 1. But, densities can be larger than 1.
In fact, if this package were to arrive between
3 minutes and 3 minutes and 1 second, then
this would be 60 because there are 60
seconds in a minute. So, it is possible that
densities become larger than 1; that’s a bit
confusing if you think it was probability. But
, you should know that this is the case.